en fait de ce que de ce que j'ai appris
il ya un peu de ya un peu dans le gaz
entre les deux parce que ils ont acheté
une maison elle a voulu retourner à los
angeles vous savez alors la maison fait
1200 m² ya neuf chambres sept salles de
bain trois hectares
ou alors qu'ils sont 4 1 alors qu'ils
sont quatre voilà ben
non en fait c'est pas si gainey a pris
le relais en fait elle et elle et elle
est à toi là-bas est alors allé
c'est une autre milliardaire la maison
elle lui lance je te peu près dans l'est
dans les 15 millions c'est une des moins
chères ou oprah winfrey ça ça vaut 100
millions à côté et en fait enlever une
plus belle plus grande plus grosse pour
une raison c'est qu'aux états unis
jean-michel notamment en californie la
marijuana vous pouvez la cultiver et la
fumée quand pour des raisons médicales
et il ya un champ juste à côté donc elle
a des vapeurs don de deux miroirs mais
qu'elle apporte lui dévore tout ça parce
qu'on est offert en fait elle veut
déménager
l'argent ne rentre pas ils ont consigné
des contrats énormes sauf que les
contrats on leur a pas donné l'argent
leur a dit ça va aller avec n'explique
jusqu'à 100 millions et spotify jusqu'à
25 millions et ne rien toucher mais en
fait ils ont commencé un peu à toucher
les choses sauf que rien ne se vend et
la sortie d'une biographie ça s'est
vendu à 3500 exemplaires en angleterre
ils ont fait des spotify pour coder des
podcasts qui n'ont pas marché non ça ne
marche pas tout ce qui fonde marcherait
de la prime en fait le seul au contraire
quand elle porte un t-shirt apparemment
ils soldats ou quand elle était en
angleterre et depuis les etats-unis
effectivement ils n'intéressent plus
personne bavarois et rennes et puis du
coup sûr mon ami histoire états unis la
monarchie anglaise ne leur envoie
plupart l'argent plus d'argent ça va la
couronne la cour a en fait la couronne
ne brille plus en angleterre kaka que
sous le soleil de californie et surtout
tous les people qui étaient leurs amis
commencent à s'éloigner d'eux parce
qu'ils ont compris qu'en fait c'était un
peu fini et qu' il fallait mieux miser
sur kate et william parce que kate et
william ça va durer pendant pendant
beaucoup plus longtemps donc il n'y a
plus vraiment d'argent mais là c'est un
peu compliqué il ya des infos closer au
cyber magazine qu'on parle aussi parce
que sur 10 ans megan de faire de la
politique on andy goode ça alors déjà ce
que dit guillaume est vrai par rapport à
la maison il y avait quand même avec la
maison à dire qu'il y aurait des ours
des coyotes qui se baladent réel mais
nous avons toujours des clients
eh bien oui c'est vrai il ya de la boue
en général je suis à paris
sérieux coup les goûts donc c'est un
terrain qui est un peu sinueux on va
dire et franchement ils sont pas très
bien il ya autre chose aussi toujours
par rapport à ce que des et guillaume
sait que la maman de megan habitent à
los angeles que là ils sont un peu
esseulé ils n'ont pas d'amis ils n'ont
pas de famille et qu' il serait possible
qu'ils se rapprochent de los angeles
voilà c'est ce qui se dit c'est ce qui
s'enrichiront pas d'alliance ans mais là
ça il suffit pas d'être riche pour voir
des amis et puis ils ont quitté alors
qu'elle était américaine méhari il est
anglais après toute la famille tous ses
amis tous ses proches ont sont en
angleterre c'est pas évident aussi riche
que tu sois quand tu changes de pays et
donc c'est vrai qu'elles ont gaspillé
beaucoup de tabloïds anglais qui disait
sereine ce qui est sur le point de se
séparer sa non pardon mais si les
anglais de notre ami 10 as et qui est
aussi un fantasme en angleterre sur
l'arène [ __ ] le bordel dans les coupes
n'oubliez pas il ya le syndrome diana il
ya toujours ce fantasme de voir ses
parts et voilà et comme il a fait des
choix particulier tous les ans on aura
ils vont séparer un jour on s'est
vraiment séparés parce que les couples
dur j'avais 10 ans non en vrai ils ont
des problèmes de thunes oui regardons la
fumette qui la dérange je repars en quoi
tu divorces tu te retrouves ta belle
mère tu divorces pas sauvé lorsque leurs
primes de thunes ces bêtes sont dit que
dans le beaucoup mais on dépense
énormément pour la sécurité de sa
l'argent ne rentre plus puisque ce
qu'ils avaient fait au début pour oprah
et tous étaient sûrs de l'argent aux
associations et maintenant ils ne
rentrent plus ils ont résulté de la
reine d'angleterre mais ils ont
maintenant la monarchie royal alors la
monarchie ne leur vois plus d'argent
mais me détroit incroyable la reine
d'angleterre n'a toujours jamais vu une
bête ils y vivaient voilà leur fille
donc pour l'instant été levée on fêtera
ses un an en juin prochain et même
moment dix ans de règne de la reine et
ça c'est potentiellement quelques chaque
bol la reine apprennent compliqué au
niveau des as mais pourquoi bruins ont
pas de tunes passent qui branle rien ils
ont pris des contrats
ils ont touché 18 millions de spotify
pour faire des podcasts sur leur vie que
c'est à ils ont été capables de sortir
une vidéo de 30 minutes sur leurs
vacances hors vacances j'ai fait aux
baléares j'ai pas où ils ont balancé ça
comme ça 18 millions pour voir megan
aura parasol sur la plage plus ça ne
vaut pas il doit écrire sa biographie la
pagaille clean la moindre ligne et que
c'est donc l'argent entre pâle ils ont
déjà touché vous maintenant les gens qui
les pousse au contraire à la politique
mais voilà vendre air pour finir enfin
depuis qu'elle est retourné aux états
unis elle est extrêmement draguer par le
clan démocrate qui voudrait que megan
puisse éventuellement faire de la
politique le problème c'est que si par
hasard elle y aller elle ne pourrait pas
être présidente des états unis en étant
mariée au profit au petit fils léo fils
et sa chef d'état parce que quand
charles des chefs d'état donc c'est pas
possible donc il faudrait qu'elle épouse
un gros texan qu'elle s'en sépare qui
sera beaucoup plus riche
d'allemagne à trois ans à dire que cette
mégane aller [ __ ] la merde et que
c'était une mauvaise nouvelle
je sens que guillaume c'est ta première
et dernière émission ici je sens les
gens